I'm going to do a little bit uh
something a little bit different today
and we're going to tell a little story a
little paral on uh quantum mechanics and
general relativity and I think it's
appropriate for uh what these folks have
done for the last 100 years here you
have people who have degrees PhD degrees
you know they they've been at the
University for 10 years at least they
are professionals now and they believe
some of the
explanations the ridiculous explanations
that have been passed on from decade to
decade to the people who are graduates
today that are out there doing soall
physics what they do is mathematical
physics followed by the most irrational
physical interpretations that you can
imagine and it's incredible that after
2,000 years or more right
this is what we ended up with uh this is
what they uh learn this is what they
preach this what they believe in and
this is what the world uh also believes
because they take it on the basis of
authority anyways we're going to get on
uh with our
story and uh it's a little corny story
and again it's maybe a propriate for uh
the topics that we're going to be
dealing with which is quantum mechanics
and general relativity okay so here's
the name of the story it's gullible's
travel once upon a time in a far far
away land a hunter found a babe in the
woods an innocent babe in a
basket having little alternative the
hunter took the abandoned basket to his
log cabin and gave the babe in the woods
the name of
Johnny Johnny grew up he would run
around uh uh and the town's folk got to
know him very well Johnny was quite
popular but for the wrong reasons the
villagers eventually came to realize
that Johnny was as candid as they come
and that he would forever be a babe in
the
woods so naive was he that you could
sell him the Empire State Building
twice Johnny was so innocent and simple
Ed that he believed
everything anyone told him he never
challenged even the most absurd stories
especially if they came from what he
believed to be authoritative
individuals eventually everyone in town
took him for the village idiot and
smirked behind his back because of his
irrational ways of thinking and
ridiculous beliefs in enre scenario was
even funnier because Johnny mistakenly
thought that they were actually amused
by his fantastic
ideas at some point the town's folk
began to call him gullible a name he was
mighty proud of and the name
stuck now gulal as he highly was was
curious about the small world of Adams
and wondered about the big world of
stars and
galaxies he wanted to know how the
universe works and why it works the way
it
does it was then that he decided it was
time to travel he would venture to far
away lands and talk with leading
University Scholars to learn more about
Mother Nature's
world so off he went seeking His Holy
Grail on a personal journey of
enlightenment one day gulo came across a
widely traveled man who was selling
intelligent
potions the sick Peddler took a single
look at gliu and sized them up at
once Adams yeah ly why don't you go down
to the land of Lily put a world where
tiny people who are very small minds
have already figured out the invisible
realm of
particles but if you do it would do well
to take this wondrous potion it'll make
you
smarter gullible thought that both were
great ideas in fact idea OTS or as
friendly traveling man said under his
breath when he bat him goodbye
idiot so off went gullible to the
quantum land of liliput a land of atoms
and
electrons taking with him all the
intelligence that he could muster as
well as all the flask of Kool-Aid the
used car salesman managed to unload onto
him the Sentinel in Lily put saw
gullible approach and yelled who goes
there
ulable yeah you look to part two thank
you sir so what's your business
gullible I came to learn about Adams no
brother that's one that bites the dust
you didn't by any chance uh see a
scumbag selling potions on the way down
here did you oh yes in fact this
friendly man directed me to your Quantum
world that figures sure why not gullible
go ahead just make sure you bring your
head back with
you so gullible went straight to see the
wisest sage in the tiny antor of Adams a
renowned scholar named Stevie
Hawk hello Dr Stevie Hawk They told me
you're the science Guru the man who
knows everything about
Adams hulke rolled his eyes they come
Dumber every day it's that snake oil
Peddler Who Sold us all those
intelligence potions who sends
them yeah sure gullible I'm the Man step
right into my lab and I'll tell you all
about
him
oh by the way Professor do you have
credentials do you have authority to
convince me Hulk stared in disbelief
this fell for real or the palace Unix
playing another one of their jokes on me
of course I do gullible I have both a
PhD and a
dhp a
dhp yeah oh uh what's a
dhp a dhp is a dogghouse
parrot only people who are able to
recite for batim where previous
dogghouse parrots taught them by rot get
the darn
diploma hopefully after you leave here
our great Lily P gamebridge University
will confer upon you a
dhp the dhp gives you authority to
repeat everything you memorize like a
parrot oh yes Dr Hawk I do hope so I'll
do my best to memorize every word you
said well you see gble the atom consists
of a tiny bead that orbits a bigger
ball we know this because we are small
smart people and can see what the big
gullies like you
can't we call the orbiting bead the
electron electron is an elementary
particle meaning that it's so small that
it actually has no structure as you can
see for yourself it's not made of
anything smaller the electron has no
length width or height no volume or
radius no size or
shape it's just a tiny mass that has
charge and
energy you know like a vibrating field
whatever that is
the electron is so small so tiny that it
looks like the letter
e except that it always carries a minus
sign with it that's how gullies like you
will recognize it amazing Professor do
you have a picture of the electron that
I can take back to my
villagers of course what did you think
in fact I'll do you one
better here's a movie of the zero
dimensional electron in motion that you
can show to all your um gullible friends
some of our top doghouse parrots at the
liliput University filmed it with their
um Zero Dimensional camera you know an
invisible film of
course and you can also take with you a
pretty little chart with pretty little
pictures of all the other pretty little
particles that our doghouse parrots at
the lilyput University have interviewed
and filmed and
photographed there's the muon that looks
like an m and the gluon that looks like
a g the upark has the shape of a view
and of course the one facing downwards
looks like a d but above all
drumbeat the all important higs the
particle of kilogram
which coincidentally adopted form of the
Harvard
age I'm eternally grateful for all this
state-of-the-art information Dr Stevie
Hawk and I intend to share it with all
the people in my Village well hopefully
they are like you gullible and believe
all this slily put and uh Quantum stuff
oh I believe they will Dr Hawk but
unfortunately they are not near as smart
as me you mean you're the top of the
line my God what's the world coming
to well glio here's your dhp your
dogghouse parrot diploma and you can
also take the movie of the electron in
the standard model and you can shove it
up your G friends arm uh NOS holes you
know so they become smarter through
osmosis info flowing to a region where
the D live see around someday gullible
don't let the door hit you in your
butt so off went gullible gleefully out
of the quantum land of Lily put with his
potions and photos and videos in dhp
convinced that he had learned a lot from
the scientific master of that magic
Realm
so gullible as he certainly was hi to
another land the land of the big a land
of warp time in alternative realities
known as
binag there he hoped to learn what the
giant minds of that world had discovered
about the origin of our universe and the
invisible stuff that filled its
landscape G arrived at the enormous
Gates of brag castle and senel saw him
coming
F5 F I smelled the blood of a candid man
what's your name
squirt I'm gulli yeah you looked a part
twoo thank you what's your business
squark I came to learn about the
universe from the Great Sage of
brang oh brother you didn't by any
chance happen to come across a no good
snake oil Peddler that sold us all them
fake intelligence pills did you oh
yes that honest man sold me all these
pills at a bargain price and told me
about all the knowledge that robing Nang
relativity University accumulated over
the years I see well what the hell go on
in gullible you can only hurt yourself
it's on your watch it's your warp time
don't dilate
mine so GLI was directed towards the
wisest man of the University of
Relativity a professor known by all as
Aly what's your name Quark I'm g
s you certainly don't have to convince
me why do I always get all these
bons I suppose it was the loudmouth used
car salesman that sold us all those
intelligence pills that sent you here oh
yes and if you need more of them I have
my napsack
bottles I don't doubt that one
bit so what do you want to know
gowell Dr Aly I would like to know what
there is in the night sky and how it all
works they told me that since you people
are so big you are so closer to the sky
and can see up close H but before you do
Dr Annie could you please tell me for my
peace of mind whether you have any
credentials
credentials oh no one has more
credentials than
me I was kned three times by Her
Excellency Queen hwome feathers of
Relativity I have a CBE and an
OB and even an order of the Garter um
that was for picking up the Queen's
undergarments one
night oh sir I tip off my hat and curtsy
before you I wish I could have half as
many
metals I see now that your name is quite
appropriate for you so let me educate
you uh Gable if that's at all
possible as you see the night sky is
filled with these Zero Dimensional
singularities we call black holes and
one-dimensional wormholes that connect
us to other universes there are also
mysterious invisible Dark Matter
particles vibrating in the background
and 40 space times it's all very obscure
and
unimaginable but as you well said here
in bra dang we can see them because we
have big eyesight and long
telescopes so you've seen these zero
invisible structures Professor see them
well we filmed and took pictures of them
here's a picture of a black hole our
dogghouse parrots took
recently you have dogghouse parrot
degrees here too of course we
do and here we have one of our top ghps
sliding down a
wormhole sh you made my day I never
expected to learn so much in just a
matter of seconds my time was definitely
dilated today and I believe I got my
shot of science for the entire year I
promise I will convey all this
information to the villagers back
home may I
inquire whether they are more or less
like you like me not quite sir Ry you
see they aren't nearly as smart as me to
make matters worse they haven't tried
the intelligence potion I bought from
that nice man at the on the road to Lily
put I
see well here's an OB and a CB and your
special dogghouse parrot for you you
have those two of
course we have internationally
recognized institutions over
here we can't give you an order of the
Garter because you haven't done anything
for the ladies I hope you
understand oh thank you Professor iy
come again some other time hopefully
when I'm not around when you return
someone will be able to tell you about
alternative realities and parallel
univers multiverses the expansion of
dark energy and how we drag time around
the spinning Earth good stuff that GBL
like you have no trouble swallowing like
candies and off went gool to his
hometown to spread his Newfound
knowledge the street Bender was there
making a killing selling his Kool-Aid to
the towns fo the irony is that all of
them started making fun of gullible
after he showed them his doghouse parrot
degree the moral of this story this
corny traveler story is that if you are
like you know like
gullible it is the teacher or the
instructor the professor you know the
preacher the useed car salesman the
snake oil pedler who will place his mind
into your brain
you'll end up like you know like
gullible parodying at the
dogghouse genuine
understanding comes from reasoning and
that you can only do
yourself so don't be
gullible so there you have it folks only
one change and that's that as a result
that um there are so many people out
there that are like the villagers it's
not only good old gullible uh I decided
to change the name of the story okay and
instead of calling it gullible's
travel travels I mean uh I changed that
and called it gullible's
travel